wouldn't want anyone I love to do it I
wouldn't want anyone I know to do it but
it is the world's oldest profession
and and someone's got to do it actually
it's funny you say that so in in couple
stores this happened this I guess in the
70s this is what I learned from my my
Gen X manager at the store uh there were
actual ads for local working girls that
would be in the back at local local sex
shops someone's got to do it I mean yeah
it's illegal if we're having sex dolls
have you have you ever went to Berlin
yes right and badly there is this club
called the heaven which is a broader
basically with included with the two
glass of wine a drink or whatever you
got a blow job hey
it costs about 20 Euro
so
but then this kind of this is how you
like it honestly I don't like it about
it is profession in the world like you
say it's always going to be there and
then again in London there is a very
high percentage or youngest from
everywhere do prostitution uh the down
server in the University they say at
least once the 17 percent of the female
in the uni are done escorting job
so that's the reality of it yeah that's
so that company just makes really great
toys like in general like the
engineering is just like off the wall oh
my goodness but um
yeah they teach you a lot about
engineering no it's really interesting
because they have to get down to the
female orgasm and they have to engineer
that so I just think it's like a
fascinating like I don't know but must
have a good research uh well they make
you go through training it's weird yeah
so wow okay so the female
is uh for women to get to that point now
a lot of them are using toys to do that
so that means that does it does that
mean that men are going to become
obsolete
um I think that like I think men have a
total misunderstanding of toys and this
is my perspective um so like there are
some women that I think
are replacing men with toys but I think
those kind of women you just see them be
very sex positive and single on social
media and you're like come on girl like
at some point you're gonna want a
boyfriend right but no matter what kind
of toy you get it's still it's not gonna
replace you know the weight of a man the
breath of a man feeling his skin on your
skin so it only it only goes so far
right but I think also people forget
this you know statistically uh a lot of
women aren't climaxing so like it might
not it's not just it doesn't get yes yes
and so uh some women are in
relationships and they're getting these
toys to make sure that they can get
there in the bedroom with their partner
but then is it isn't it better than for
men and women to have these
conversations as to how to give a woman
an orgasm wouldn't that be better than
to just be like getting a toy well I
mean I don't it depends because every
woman's anatomically different too like
I mean we'll get in the weeds with that
but I won't get too too far into it but
what I will say is that I do think that
there is a social phenomenon of female
worship like self-worship you know like
like sex isn't even about being it being
between a man and woman I'm doing this
for myself I'm an independent woman I
can you know get myself off and I think
that that's like disgusting and not at
all romantic so that I think is true but
you know are women replacing mammoth
toys I mean I think it's possible but
the only woman that I thought the only
woman that I saw in the store over the
year working there where I was like very
sure that I think this woman is
replacing them with toys they're like
the most ugly women I've ever seen in my
life I was like nobody's trying to tap
that I'm sorry redhead from P feminist
no just well no like you know like 300
pounds you know just like on Camp
probably meth heads I don't even know
alcoholics it was bad but it's it's hard
to say I mean the the the sale of the of
the toys may have have gone up
exponentially but who who's like like
you say who's actually buying it because
I mean I walked through Soho before and
there's quite a few adverts up for um
outside a couple of sex shops I think
probably because of because Halloween
was just just was uh just gone and um
it's they seem to be targeted at couples
actually it seems to be sort of like oh
you know she can dress up in this cute
outfit for him and you can use this toy
and it seems to be more like that and
actually when I've been into those
stores with girls because I've done that
sometimes you know we go on a date be
like oh let's have a look in here haha
you know it's a bit sexy sort of thing
um you'll often see couples in there
actually more than I mean this is purely
anecdotal so I don't know but but I do
wonder I think it's is it because
Society is becoming more more sexualized
sexualized more sex positive and so
these things can be introduced into the
into the bedroom as part of a
relationship as opposed to these women
just going off on their own and you know
yeah and women can overuse the toys as
well so that could present a problem so
if you're talking about like women reply
a woman who's replacing a man yeah you
yeah you're gonna know because you're
not gonna be able to do anything because
she didn't like fried her Bean off she
didn't fried it off is that the
technical term
as well yeah doctor I've got a problem
you fragile yeah
I'm sorry to say Miss Drummond you fried
your Beetle
did you see the news come out a few days
ago when Pope Francis say even London
priest watch board you know and that's
why I don't [ __ ] with Catholics
that's really funny to me no I swear to
God this is why this is why there's a
group of people that have no home when
it comes to religion because I grew up
12 years Catholic school and now these
Popes are wild and now what on Earth why
is he saying that uh because it's a fact
you know to see what are you say it Pope
Francis you can find the BBC News
it's a basically uh he complained about
that there are too many Temptation even
for for priests and none because it's
been find out the watching porn right so
we're talking about news come out three
days ago I'm coming from an old Catholic
family my family you know I go even a
bishop in my family my grandmom uh was
hoping I become a priest because I'm
coming from an old old family at the
third son in a in a family supposed to
become a priest right but it didn't
happen obviously right so but it's
understanding now the facility to have
with internet I mean when we were kids
maybe probably the older in here you're
lucky if you can see a picture of a girl
naked in somewhere then nowadays you can
see a full porn movie on your mobile
whatever your age is so again sexuality
is the problem because you know interact
with people right even when you go a
partner you don't know
what are the trigger points now you need
to understand you know that Dynamic how
they enjoy you know sexuality together
it's not always the same you know that's
why when I start to talk to the man
they're looking at me like the pizza
because nobody asked a question normally
when they go in the bed they go but I
need to know you know I start to having
sex when I was 13. right wow yeah 13 19
17 I didn't get he's Italian Guys okay
he's Italian but it wasn't the common it
wasn't the common at the time again born
in 1971 right so it was difficult to
interact with guests as I say to you I
am clearly not for you at 13.
again because you start to interact with
gas they were in Italian so they were
German becoming iterative study so
they've been living that so they didn't
have a really friend they didn't have
any issue with the family but I always
been careful so I never make anyone
pregnant in my life right I always been
like I grew up with really with a
traditional know if you go if you got
sex and then you have a child you pay
for it you know you don't you you have
no children you have no kids I got no
kids man every shot got to be account
that's my granddad was a cop as well so
as I say very straight old-fashioned and
no one in my family I got over 100
000 at kids outside relationship no one
wow I know it's very unusual so when I
talk to people say I got kids that I
call you there
I mean did they teach you even if they
didn't teach you right you got more
information now the way we used to be
have when we were teenager right I think
is a big issue in a way not not because
it's not supposed to be be there because
it will be there but people got too much
force informational cities in reality uh
and if you speak with people in the in
the sector they tell you well
sometimes they go fake you know but they
go fake situation for close up and
nowadays probably is easier to do a
movie because it's in digital so you can
roll in no stop but back in the days
they used to be shot in film right and
film costs money and thinking about
moving a big camera around to changing
sin especially with the poor actor did
they use Viagra you have to stay up is
an issue so you have to be quick about
it it's a real skill set it's a real
skill
that's wonderful that hardcore movie
because all the hard to me we have a we
have a we have a colleague actually
sterling sterling Cooper he was a a a an
adult entertainment actor and he talks
about this but that is the key thing for
the mail pool to be able to you know
before but now this is
so I have a question as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible